line up beside your best friends  jump forward and jump forward again  i know a little direction is all you  need so follow my lead follow my lead  we're  [Music]  what do we call this dance  directionality  eyes up and raise your hands high  take one step backwards and clap for me  for time  let me see you jumping around let me see  you drop  let me see you freeze when you hear the  beast stop  come together and form a straight line  reach for the shoulders of whomever  you're behind  now start to march let the leader  control the speed just follow their lead  follow the lead  we're dancing forward we're dancing back  we're dancing up down the sideways and  that's a fact  this guy can take us to where we want to  be what do we call this dance  directionality we're dancing forward  we're dancing back we're dancing back  we're dancing up down and sideways and  lots of  facts can take us to where we want to  [Music]  be nationality  [Music]